which will be available in july we are
told the new macbook is thinner
lighter and faster
well that sounds fancy
thinner lighter faster
mad respect for people who actually work
in this heat and going to
my pool guy travis
wow that's it we've got some serious
heat this week travis do a nice job at
the pool does a great job does an
excellent job so he just got a shout out
on tv he really did and he deserves it
right so do all the pool men and women
yes temperatures of course we call it
excessive heat guys because we're
getting to dangerous readings okay when
we say that because most of the
population going to be under this this
heat watch or heat warning i should say
and of course this is temperatures we
have not seen
since september it has been that long we
haven't gotten acclimated to it and
that's the reason for why the national
weather service issued the excessive
heat warning and thank you for doing
that flow facts for you las vegas's
hottest temp last year was
117 degrees that was on july 10th and
ironically that's also the hottest
official temp ever for las vegas and
we've reached that three times one of
them was uh last year 117 degrees 103
for sky canyon right now centennial's
104 106 for north las vegas 105 sunrise
manor 102 for mountains edge all areas
at triple digits for sure hottest
temperature so far today 100 for prompt
106 for mesquite you're 114 out there in
death valley wow you're all indoors i
hope 108 for laughlin and sandy valley
currently at 99 degrees so there's that
jet stream again that ridge forming just
to the north now and each day is going
to get hotter it will peak again we
think on friday or saturday so here's
the latest hottest week of the season
this week for sure we call it a heatwave
this is definitely a heat wave all right
each day gets hottest looks like friday
now we'll be at 109 108 on saturday the
records for those days are uh 108 and
109. so it looks like right now and i
told you this earlier this week that
these numbers could change and they have
looks like friday will set a new record
at 109 degrees break the previous record
of 108 saturday come very close to that
possibly tying it on saturday with that
108 forecast that we're calling for so
here's your
numbers overnight 82 degrees that's your
morning numbers so in the evening we're
still talking maybe the mid 90s by the
time i go on for eight news now at 11.
warming overnight
breezy evening expected 106 for tomorrow
the heat warning starts at 10 a.m and it
will be breezy at times also through
most of your day for tomorrow your highs
neighborhood by neighborhood here you go
spring valley 105 for you same for north
las vegas aliante included hotter for
you in green valley at 108 along with
sunrise manor in areas like nellis 104
for henderson and safer mountains edge
106 for southern highlands outside the
valley even hotter death valley 117 112
for you in laughlin one team's there 104
for boulder city and 103 for uh uh prop
over the hump here's your eight day
forecast now we do have those winds like
we talked about strongest winds will be
on sunday
and then we'll see those numbers drop
then we'll be right near average believe
it or not on monday and tuesday but then
the heat returns by midweek next week
coming up i'm going to show you how
strong those winds on sunday will get
and what to expect all coming up in your
weather
now brian over here all right ted